coven 19 has killed more than 300 000
people
in the united states in 2020 but that's
just the known death toll
scientists and families who have lost
their relatives across the country
say the real figure is likely much
higher the total number of code debts
that we have in the us is really an
under count of the
full burden of the pandemic when the cdc
looked at how many more people had died
nationwide this year compared to
previous years
it found that coven 19 only accounted
for around two-thirds of those deaths
meaning up to 100 000 additional deaths
hadn't been officially attributed to the
pandemic
the number of additional deaths compared
to previous years is known as
excess deaths and many experts see it as
a starting point to determine the real
death toll from the pandemic
and so when we look at 2020
and the cova deaths there's clearly an
excess mortality
and then the question is what is that
excess mortality made up of
that's the puzzle that statisticians
healthcare workers and policymakers are
all racing to solve
and it may take years you know these
things are not
as black and white as you might expect
but understanding exactly how people
died can help governments fight the
virus more effectively
and determine things such as where to
send vaccines first
and whether lockdowns are effective so
how will we know how many people really
died from covid in america
i have today declared that the
coronavirus presents a public health
emergency in the united states
when the pandemic first hit the u.s in
february epidemiologists like dan
weinberger from meal public school of
health
began comparing how many excess deaths
they were seeing against the official
covet death figures
especially early on there was a pretty
considerable gap between the number of
reported
coveted deaths and the total number of
deaths that occurred professor
weinberger believes that this gap which
you can see here
is caused by two main factors the first
is a term called collateral deaths
where people have been killed not by the
covet virus but have died due to the
wider impacts of the pandemic
in michigan six hospitals have reached
capacity this week
as hospitals are getting more and more
overwhelmed by the pandemic
simply the ability to care for people as
well as we should
simply goes away in some cases
researchers say people have died because
healthcare facilities were overwhelmed
or people simply wanted to avoid
hospitals
we know that especially early on in the
pandemic a lot of people were avoiding
emergency care
for things like heart attacks and
strokes and that can certainly
contribute
to the number of people who are dying
the second category is covet deaths that
have been certified as something else
and professor weinberger believes it's
this category that makes up the vast
bulk of those non-coveted excess deaths
determining the cause of death for a
death certificate is
a bit of an art there are often multiple
contributing factors
so you can imagine that someone gets an
infection with covate and then they
develop pneumonia
perhaps have a heart attack and die and
then there's a question of
what gets recorded as the underlying
cause of death on the death certificate
one person who makes those decisions is
dr james gill connecticut's chief
medical examiner
he has made it his mission to find covet
deaths that had been misclassified in a
state
we don't want to be just arbitrary and
say well if they've ever been
coveted positive we're going to make it
a code of death no
you really have to look at the
circumstances in the clinical history
and make sure that kovid 19 is still
playing or played some kind of
pathologic role
in the death dr gill started testing
bodies at funeral homes after seeing a
slew of death certificates at the
beginning of the pandemic
with pneumonia a respiratory failure
listed as the cause
if it said respiratory failure that
would
give us a tip-off that maybe this was a
covet death that had been missed
his team performed some 175 post-mortem
coven 19 swaps
at funeral homes in his state uh 110
tested positive uh for covid we were
able to
identify dozens of deaths
uh that would not have been identified
as a covadef
uh but for our investigation dr gil
believes many covet deaths may have been
missed due to a shortage of available
testing
for both the dead and the living testing
kits have become easier to find after
shortages in may
we had trouble getting enough nasal
pharyngeal swabs
to test i was calling up local hospitals
saying can you give me 20 can you give
me 25
they just weren't available
unfortunately again people think of well
the medical examiners are just dealing
with dead people you don't need to be a
priority we need to deal with the living
and i absolutely understand that and
agree with that to a certain
point but as i you know but our work
does affect the living as well
so how does understanding how people
have died help us exactly
the disruptions caused by the pandemic
are
obviously unprecedented in in recent
history
having a better understanding of the
severity of the pandemic
can allow us to make more informed
choices and
we can allow the public to decide
whether those decisions are justified or
not
the excess deaths data can also give
insights into how vaccines should be
rolled out
you know the excess deaths have
particularly hit certain vulnerable
populations
especially hard certain lower uh
lower income populations in communities
of color it can help in
sort of planning for the next phase of
the pandemic thinking about who should
be vaccinated first and where we might
want to
focus prevention efforts
as there are limited resources to fight
the pandemic this data is crucial to
help identify high priority areas and
inform policy decisions
in addition you know people just want to
know a family member
you want to know if your brother dies
your father dies why did they die
you know is this a cove of death uh and
so
you know i hate to use the term closure
but that is something that i think
helps people with their bereavement
and so they can understand but for those
seeking closure
the answers may still take time while
professor weinberger says data from this
pandemic is still being analyzed at an
unprecedented rate
it still typically takes years to
account for those unknown excess deaths
yeah i think it is going to take some
time
with the current pandemic just because
we're going to have to be patient and
wait for the data to be released
and you know that could take another one
to two years from now